I hope this will be a truly offensive
occasion since that's what who I
discussed but there's a paradox before
we really get going which is that of
course the subject in part that we're
discussing is no platforming and there
no platform is on the platform for
obvious reasons which is rather
unrolling when you think about it but I
will try and represent the arguments in
the course of this for no platforming
altogether
last year I learned voted to get rid of
its blasphemy laws and most applauded
the new right to offend the Catholic
Church we also expect our press and our
mediums to be viciously critical or even
offensive to our leaders yet to avoid
giving offence student campuses are
introducing no platforming and safe
spaces should we see to it eradicate
offense to create a more tolerant and
equal society or is offensive vital to
freedom and a critical means of
containing the powerful we got a
cracking panel for you on my right is
Johnny Williams she's the author of
women vs feminism an associate editor of
a political magazine spiked and the head
of education and culture at policy
exchange
yes ma'am alibi Brown is on my immediate
left a very respected pundit who writes
regularly for the I International
Business Times and new European and
David Orana [ __ ] on the far left well
he was once but no longer
he's an odd winning journalist and
broadcaster he once worked for the BBC
he writes a regular column to the times
he sits on the board of the index on
Censorship
joanna so i think the right to be
offensive is absolutely vital in a
society that purports to oppose a belief
in free speech for one thing we don't
need the right to free speech for what's
inoffensive we can be as bland and as
boring as we like and nobody's ever
going to challenge us we only need the
right to be the right to free speech and
it becomes meaningful and important when
we're going to say things that might
upset other people my second argument is
that free speech and most importantly
the right to be
offensive is necessary for society to
advance if you think about all the major
leaps forward we've made as a society
whether we're talking about abolishing
slavery universal suffrage gay marriage
anything you can think of evolution all
of these ideas have grossly offended
some sections of society and if we
didn't have the right to offend we
wouldn't have been able to argue for
those our cause as which I think we
would all agree now are hugely
progressive and really important we need
to be able to offend to make the case
for those things
the final point I'd make and this is
where I am so sorry asthma but I just
don't know why you would be here today
if you think words can't change its
cause debates oh yes yes exactly debates
so important to try and change people's
minds to change people's views ideally
because words are important what's a
very important time indeed because
however much we might wish it were
otherwise we can't just magic bad ideas
away and there are an awful lot of bad
ideas out there in the world and we need
to begged we need the right to be
offensive we need free speech to be able
to challenge those bad ideas husband
your outline I think bad ideas or good
ideas
yes require words and bravery but I
don't think there is a duty on free
speeches to offend and that's the
problem people think they're being
awfully brave when they pick on certain
groups and not on others and
deliberately set out to offend them
I have four letters from four wannabe
novelists who sought from me a comment
to suggest that they should have the
fatwa because their sales would go up I
don't think there's a duty to offend
there is a right you're gonna name them
I'm no novelists who wanted a fatwa I
can give the rule itself to us so I
think there is civilized discourse I
think absolutely I agree with you that
difficult ideas need to be argued for
but ideologues and people who are set in
their ways it's a waste of my
timon there's but also let me just quote
somebody I really admire Deborah or who
says who really thinks the right to
offend is inalienable who believes that
some hideous error was made when it
became untenable to put up notices on
your pub saying no blacks no Irish no
dogs who thinks those were better times
and that's where I'm coming from there's
a limit there are people who set out to
offend certain groups of people and
there are people who are brave and they
who are arguing in very difficult
circumstances there are issues that are
very difficult to argue without being
threatened and being and and that does
cause upset but my problem is that free
rah free speech warriors now think it's
their duty to demean and insult and
dehumanize groups of people often those
who are powerless and I can't go with
that David um I think I'm going to begin
by quarreling which is a really bad
thing to do with the title of the
session but only in this sense I don't
really think that offense is the big
question here it is for some people and
quite often and in fact we've just heard
an example of it when people use the
term offense they actually mean
something different which is they mean
are there things that people can do can
say which are dangerous for other people
and if they're we believe there are what
are our is our ability if we have it to
stop them a worse danger in the round
than the things that they are saying and
I think that's really what the debates
about free speech is about so let me
give an obvious example which we could
come down to the problem of hate speech
and by the way what we can see on on
this freedom of speech question is a
kind of pendulum which was swinging very
much in favor of free speech in almost
every regard but I'm talking about the
Democratic West largely until the advent
of social media about a decade ago
and after that we've been in a perpetual
war about what should be permitted and
what shouldn't be permitted because of
the ability effectively of anybody and
everybody to make to publish an
expression and have it seen by everybody
I mean to give you an example if one of
you would stand up at the back now and
start shouting epithets at us etc
somebody probably nice from the festival
would come in and hustle them away oh no
no I didn't measure to express their
opinions and see if there was a brain
behind the remarks right when when
Rogers presenting his program on radio
for think he likes above all is for
people to burst into the studio when
it's encouraged without some life very
unfair it's a great program anyway
that's what I think I should leave
should we just look at a couple of
things that underline this let's start
by the suggestion is that certainly
people need protecting not us but as an
argument people need protecting
supposing that has a stable disabled
person out there and I call in a [ __ ]
now I would have used that term 40 years
ago now it's offensive if I use the word
[ __ ] which some people said I
shouldn't use at all the assumption is
that there are people out there so
offended and so vulnerable to offense
that they need to be protected now is
there at the case and in which case is
there need to be protected so great that
the rest of us should moderate what we
say Joanna can you think of cases where
simply because of how much a small
sectional study would be hurt we should
not say something no I can't and and as
I I mean I'm a free speech absolutist I
mean I'll be absolutely clear about this
I I am a free speech absolutist but I
think the point you're making really
illustrates for me one of the reasons
why I am a free speech absolutist
because I think if you actually bring
prejudice back in through the back door
when you start defining limits to free
speech so you start saying
some groups of people are more sensitive
or less easy to cope with debate are
just more vulnerable than others so we
start with something that those peoples
who are going to be genuinely hurt you
say to them it's too bad it's in the
greater good
I think the corollary are you saying
that that they've just have to put up
with it for the greater world now I'm
not actually because I think if I had
anybody using the words that you you
used I would argue back against them I
would say no can you not use these words
probably going to pay no attention and
the question read the implicit question
here is should we be taking action to
stop the expression either of those
views of that language because there may
be people will be hurt and you're saying
I think you must be saying there may be
people who would be hurt but there's a
larger issue I am saying that but I'm
not saying I am saying yes there's a
larger issue you're absolutely right I'm
saying people might be hurt but there's
a larger issue and the larger issue is
free speech but I'm also not saying that
everybody in the world has to turn into
this kind of really tough individual and
just take it all on the chin and we
should all go around throwing the most
offensive insults at the most vulnerable
people in society and just expect them
to kind of lap it up in the name of free
speech I'm saying Society is a
collective and as a collective if we see
people saying things we disagree with we
can argue back against them we can say I
disagree with what you've said we can
stick up for other people and I think
that solidarity where we act
collectively to defend and to stick up
for people is really important to that
but the first legislation takes away our
ability to act in solidarity with others
welcomes legislation later but David can
I is it can we make a distinction
between ideas and facts can we say and I
ask you as a Jew this question Holocaust
denial versus if you like criticism of
Jews more generally or Israel is there a
way you could disagree where you say
Society has an obligation to say these
facts exist
opinions about the causes were fine but
the facts can't be denied I'm thinking
back to a situation where for example I
understand some Japanese schools history
books don't refer to Manchuria and what
the Japanese did in Manchuria so you
don't know the appalling things that
happened and elsewhere so is can you
make that distinction what that's an
interesting that you should put that
example at the end because that's quite
a good example for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you